I'm Shankar Vedantam and from Hidden Brain Media, this is my unsung hero. Stories where one person reached out to help another in a time of need. Hi Shankar, my unsung hero is a Frenchman. She had given me exactly what I needed in that time. I was fortunate enough to survive with the help of this man, this doctor, who went out of his way to help save my life. Today's story comes from Senna Kerumi. Some years ago, Senna was living in France, working on a PhD. One cold winter weekend, she and her friends took a break and
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，来自“隐藏的大脑”传媒，这是我的无名英雄。讲述一个人在他人需要时伸出援手的故事。嗨，尚卡尔，我的无名英雄是一位法国男士。她在那时给予了我最需要的帮助。我很幸运，在这个男人、这位医生的帮助下得以生还，他竭尽全力帮助我拯救了生命。今天的故事来自塞娜·克鲁米。几年前，塞娜住在法国，攻读博士学位。一个寒冷的冬日周末，她和朋友们放松了一下，
spent the day at Disneyland Paris. They stayed as long as they could until it was finally time to catch the last train home. She calls it the tram. One by one, all of Senna's friends got off at their stops until she was the only one left. And I noticed that the tram was super empty, like there were just two people in there, two guys. Both of them friends, and I wear the hijabs, so I really stand out. And whenever I go, I do stand out.
在巴黎迪士尼乐园度过了一天。他们尽可能地待到很晚，直到终于到了赶最后一班回家列车的时候。她把这叫作有轨电车。塞娜的朋友们一个接一个地在各自的站点下了车，直到只剩下她一个人。我注意到有轨电车非常空，里面好像只有两个人，两个小伙子。他们俩是朋友，而我戴着头巾，所以我真的很引人注目。无论我走到哪，我都确实很引人注目。
One of the men was in the front of the tram. The other sat a few rows behind Senna. She didn't feel like either of them were paying her or her headscarf much attention, so she put on her headphones and looked out the window. Something like maybe the switch like the time between music or something like this when you have the small silence. I heard something and it turned and I saw this guy just being very agitated and he was waving his hands and swearing and just pointing in my direction and I wasn this guy just being very agitated. And he was waving his hands and swearing
其中一个男人在有轨电车的前面。另一个坐在塞娜后面几排的地方。她觉得他们俩都没有怎么注意她或她的头巾，于是她戴上耳机，看向窗外。类似于音乐之间的切换或者诸如此类的当你有一小段安静的时间。我听到了一些声音，转过头去，看到这个家伙非常激动，他挥舞着双手，满口脏话，还指着我的方向，我并不是这个家伙非常激动。他挥舞着双手，满口脏话
and just pointing in my direction. And I wasn't sure if it was me or the other guy because I didn't do anything that may trigger him to do that. So I assumed that he was probably talking to the guy behind me. I took my head's phone off and that when I heard like all those very harmful words that he was saying, that we took the jobs, that we are making Europe and civilized, that we are everything that is wrong with Europe and friends. At that woman I was like, yes, this is about me, this is differently about me. I wasn't scared. I was just numb and shocked.
而且一直指着我的方向。我不确定他是针对我还是针对另一个人，因为我没有做什么会引发他这样做的事。所以我猜测他可能是在和坐在我后面的那个家伙说话。我摘下了耳机，就在那时，我听到了他说的所有那些非常恶毒的话，说我们抢了工作，说我们在让欧洲变得野蛮，说我们是欧洲和法国一切错误之根源。在那一刻，我想，是的，这是冲着我来的，这绝对是冲着我来的。我并不害怕。我只是感到麻木和震惊。
I didn't understand why is this happening. I didn't even cross my mind that I would be in danger, but I was like, why? Why? Why? What did I do? Why? Just a set up began to stand. The man who had been sitting behind her rushed to the front of the tram and placed himself between her and the angry man. A few seconds he was up front of me and he kept on pushing the guy to the door of the tram. He kept on saying, you don't touch her, you don't say those words to her. She's just a student. Everything that's wrong with Europe is you.
我不明白为什么会发生这种事。我甚至没有想过我会处于危险之中，但我在想，为什么？为什么？为什么？我做了什么？为什么？就在这时，一个人站了起来。一直坐在她后面的那个男人冲到电车前部，挡在了她和那个愤怒的男人之间。几秒钟后，他来到了我面前，并不断把那个家伙推向电车车门。他一直说，你别碰她，你别对她说那些话。她只是个学生。欧洲一切错误之根源是你。
This phrase I remember is very clearly. Everything that is wrong with Europe is people like you. Not her. The man defending Senna kept the angry man from getting close to her. At the beginning, he kept pushing him toward the tramway door. And same time, yelling at the beginning, he kept pushing him toward the tram my door. And at the same time, yelling at the driver,
我记得很清楚的是这句话。欧洲一切错误之根源是像你这样的人。而不是她。捍卫塞娜的男人阻止了那个愤怒的男人靠近她。一开始，他一直把他往电车车门方向推。与此同时，在大声呵斥一开始，他一直把他往电车车门方向推。与此同时，在大声呵斥司机，
stopped the tram, this guy needs to get off the next station. Once the tram stopped, he pushed the man off the tram, and then stood by the doors to make sure he couldn't get back on. He stayed there, didn't talk to me, stayed by the door, it's like watching me. This happens a lot when you are veiled, and especially in France, like, when they see you as veiled,
停下电车，这家伙需要在下一站下车。电车停下后，他把那个人推下了电车，然后站在车门旁，确保他无法再上来。他一直待在那儿，没有和我说话，就站在车门旁，就像是在看着我。当你戴着面纱时，这种情况经常发生，尤其是在法国，当他们看到你戴着面纱时，
they really don't know how to interact with you. They don't know what are your boundaries. So I'm assuming that's why he didn't come and talk to me. Although it would have not been a problem at all, I probably would have welcomed it, but I'm pretty sure that that's the reason. Santa was too shocked to say anything either. She and the man stood in silence on the tram
他们真的不知道该如何与你互动。他们不知道你的底线在哪里。所以我猜测这就是他没有过来和我说话的原因。尽管这完全不成问题，我可能还会欢迎这样做，但我非常确定这就是原因。塞娜太震惊了，什么也说不出来。她和那个男人在电车上默默无言地站着
until her stop came. When she got out, the man followed and made sure she got into her building safely. Santa was still in too much shock to turn around and say thank you. It was the very first time that I encountered something like it in my entire life. I heard stories, of course I did, I knew that it happens, but I never assumed that it would happen to me. At the moment, even what the nice guy did didn't register, I was still so focused on what the bad guy said. Why was he attacking me? What did I do?
直到她的站到了。她下车后，那个男人跟着她，确保她安全进入大楼。塞娜依然处于巨大的震惊中，无法转过身去说一声谢谢。这是我一生中第一次遇到类似的事情。我听过故事，当然听过，我知道这种事会发生，但我从没想过它会发生在我身上。那一刻，甚至那个好心人所做的事都没有在我脑海中留下印象，我仍然把注意力集中在那个坏家伙说的话上。他为什么要攻击我？我做了什么？
And then somehow I was like, oh, but wait, I wasn't alone in this. There was another guy who kind of knew that I didn't do anything wrong, that I didn't deserve the hatred and the violence. And he actually defended me. And then I said, wait, he had no reason to defend me. He wasn't sharing the same beliefs and the same culture. And yet he was there, he actually put himself in danger by doing that. He could have gotten hurt, he could have gotten in so much trouble and he didn't think about that. Every time Sana experienced Islamophobia after that day, she remembered the man who defended her. Ana experienced Islamophobia after that day. She remembered the man who defended her.
然后不知怎么的，我想，哦，但是等等，我并不是孤单一人。还有另一个家伙，他某种程度上知道我没有做错任何事，我没有罪有应得地承受这种仇恨和暴力。而且他实际上保护了我。然后我说，等等，他没有理由保护我。我们没有相同的信仰和相同的文化。然而他就站在那里，他实际上通过这样做把自己置于危险之中。他本可能会受伤，本可能会惹上大麻烦，但他却没有考虑这些。从那一天起，每当塞娜经历伊斯兰恐惧症时，她就会想起那个保护她的男人。娜从那天起经历了伊斯兰恐惧症。她记住了那个保护她的男人。
His kindness and courage gave her the strength to remain in France. I don't remember it as the day where I was attacked by a stranger. I remember it as the day where I was saved by a stranger. And that made all the difference. All the difference. Listener Sena Kirumi. Some years after the incident, Sena finished her PhD and moved back to our home country of Morocco. When we spoke to her, she was working as an international management consultant.
他的善良和勇气给了她留在法国的力量。我不把它记为被陌生人攻击的日子。我把它记为被陌生人拯救的日子。这产生了所有的不同。所有的不同。听众塞娜·克鲁米。事件发生几年后，塞娜完成了博士学位，并搬回了她的祖国摩洛哥。当我们与她交谈时，她正担任国际管理顾问。
We'd love to hear about your own unsung hero. Use your phone to record your story in five minutes or less and email it to us at myunsunghero at hiddenbrain.org. You can hear many more stories like this on our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. Subscribe to that show and you never have to miss an episode. I'm Shankar Vidantam, see you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们很想听听你自己的无名英雄的故事。用你的手机在五分钟或更短的时间内录下你的故事，并将其发送到我们的邮箱：myunsunghero@hiddenbrain.org。你可以在我们的姊妹播客《我的无名英雄》中听到更多类似的故事。订阅该节目，你将永不错过任何一集。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，我们回头见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。